judge katanji brown jackson is closer to
becoming the first black woman on the
supreme court the senate voted last
night to move jackson's nomination to
the senate floor after a tied vote in
the judiciary committee two more
republican senators that's mitt romney
and lisa murkowski say they will vote in
her favor so that effectively guarantees
her confirmation when a final vote is
taken a little bit later this week
nicole killian is on capitol hill with
more on this part of the story so nicole
that's three gop senators so far why are
the why are they breaking with their
party at this time
well gail both of these senators say
that they don't agree with all of judge
jackson's decisions but they do believe
she is more than qualified to serve on
the supreme court utah senator mitt
romney called jackson a well-qualified
jurist and person of honor alaska's lisa
murkowski said in jackson's judicial
independence and temperament she was
also critical of how things were handled
and said her decision rests on her quote
rejection of the corrosive politization
of the review process for supreme court
nominees which on both sides of the
aisle is growing worse and more detached
from reality jackson continues to make
the rounds here on capitol hill again
today a final vote on her confirmation
is expected as soon as thursday tony
nicole thank you very much